[Music]
Joe you are the only single man in this
room
how has quarantine dating been for you
it's actually been pretty [ __ ]
awesome tell us all about it okay
so something happened after the whole
breakup where when I became an eligible
bachelor I wasn't even looking to get
into anything new or whatever but DMS
have been filling up with all kinds of
people and when I say people you means
fans people men women men women of all
ages ranging from 50 to underaged it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's just weird
have you doubled at all in dating yet I
try tender a little bit I tried some
when I was in Vietnam and whatever but
not really and it's just different I
think it's a different world because I
think when it comes to tinder and dating
in that realm there's a lot of having to
prove yourself and to me I don't have
time I just want [ __ ] but that's the
beauty cause like we were talking with
us the other night in the stream you a
lot of these people who are not do you
know you through watching you and stuff
yes so you do get to cut through a lot
of that [ __ ] though cuz they've
already been impressed right so here's
the theme code to like I think JK fans
are just not weird humans like they're
just normal so they don't feel like fans
you know what I mean it's almost like
you tell it all well for example Casey
was a fan right and he's our friend now
yeah and he works with us such as most
of the people that were with and I think
there's people that are quote unquote
fans that we do business with and we
became business partners with or
whatever right so it's really more like
that like there's people that I've met
where it's like oh yeah I've seen your
video maybe one or two when I was a kid
but it's not like oh my god I want every
[ __ ] one of your videos when I hear
that I'm like oh this is weird I gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here wait would you
classify fan as oh I've seen your video
here in there yeah okay well cuz it's
like how do you avoid that but you're
avoiding the weirdness know like if so
it's like I can't deny the the body of
work that we
done right so if someone might have seen
it so for example like if I made a
friend that saw my work in the past
right what isn't that making a friend
with the fan if they're engaging with
your stuff like they're a fan I would
agree with in that case I don't [ __ ]
fans okay cuz I've seen TV shows in
passing I'm not fans of those TV shows
that just happened to come on it's just
like I I know that actor and from that
one thing doesn't mean I'm a fan of that
yes so the dynamic is like so you know
like Nadeem was a mega fan but then he
doesn't show the fairness yeah and he
actually became one of our friends yeah
I like that
he's chill yeah yeah yeah but then the
cool part about it is it removes this
need of like hey just so you know I'm a
safe guy like there's that awkwardness
like I don't know if you guys remember
the dating phase where you don't know
each other and you're kind of stepping
toward each other and it takes a little
bit of time unless it's just a
straight-up hookup I like you physically
you like me physically let's just [ __ ]
but that happens very rarely at least
for me this is like if they don't know
who you are they don't even care about
what you do you just [ __ ] mathematic
club and I think that happens very
rarely for most guys unless you you
you're like a [ __ ] straight up Rico
suave yeah but when the that whole like
having to prove yourself or having to
show who you really are is removed I
feel more comfortable because I can be
myself I can say the craziest [ __ ] and
no one's looking at me weird but then
when it's strangers I can't be myself
because I know that like you have to get
some runway yeah and then you have to
ease into it I get it though you know
what I mean yeah yeah when you're cold
um with somebody like our first date
cold by like you just met him and you
just interacting for the first time
you're trying to put your best foot
forward you have to yeah right normals
people if I walk into a [ __ ] date and
I'm not like my favorite things are rim
jobs [ __ ] ice cream and Slurpees if
it came up in conversation I think okay
that's why you're one of my friend
nice little bar like that is that like
when someone doesn't get too close and
they don't do too much of the personal
[ __ ] right away you can right away go
you're a normal person right you know
you ever meet somebody and they get too
close and they tell you too many like
personal details and you're like I've
known you for five minutes
why are you telling you yeah one of
those people really yeah we get a bit
Bates about how to approach different
like groups and like meeting people for
the first time and I'm on that's why you
stick around I adjust my personality
according to who I'm with I do she
thinks that's tacky because it's like
you're being fake or like to a certain
degree right I feel like I think you you
you just you just let it all out I mean
I'm 19
so you do change who you are no yeah not
like that Oh like um like if I meet
another person that's relatively around
my age where I could consider a friend
in the future or whatever like and I
just put myself out there like I don't
but you know you putting yourself out
[ __ ] there's no consequences me putting
myself out there
there are your mild like even if you put
yourself out there no one's gonna reject
you huh
but I'm pretty weird do you like rim
jobs no what have you been - I know I'm
pretty self-aware of how I could make
someone uncomfortable no matter how much
you put yourself out there you don't
make people uncomfortable so you never
felt the consequences of being yourself
where I I have uh so when you put your
so I over the years I realized what
people are comfortable with and I don't
want to take them there until I opened
them up and I don't like that face cuz I
feel fake but I know it's a necessity
because like the way I act with my
karate club or we are a business style
or whatever like I'm still out there but
that's me holding back because I know
people who like online date and before
they even go on their first date and
they're like on tinder or texting or
whatever they'll start airing out all of
their like dirty secrets and like their
family laundry and they're like whoa we
haven't dated yet so that's what I mean
when you're like it's too much too fast
saying all of these problems and it's
like if you started at a ten when we
date what are you gonna be a twenty like
what well you know what I mean for me it
all depends on wrong speaking to two
because yeah I end up like feeling the
energy and I feel like I can like sense
how open they want to be and like how
open I can be like that's true it's not
like I'm gonna immediately talk about
how my parents got divorced no like
that's you adjusting to the room okay I
think everyone kind of just to the room
in that way if it comes up in
conversation and I'm really open and
vulnerable if it comes like if it's an
appropriate time to do it yeah like if
you meet someone like that or group or
whatever and you can tell someone's like
really pregnant proper so every time you
meet them you know oh this is their
comfort zone so when their prim and
proper you're kind of prim and proper
right but then when you're on the tour
group and you meet someone that watched
all your childhood shows [ __ ] you like a
shot to hell like there's this this type
of energy all of a sudden so you're just
kind of justing or energy you know in
case it doesn't you're just in a
different way yeah oh yeah so around
different people you adjust your slides
right oh yeah I don't take it as fake I
think I see it as being considerate yeah
of like the personal space you don't you
got to gauge them and then walk toward
it and for me I I actually like the
opposite I like to dive in so I actually
like girls that are very forward so if
they just [ __ ] go straight up and say
hey I want to [ __ ] take you out on a
date which I've had and they're like
yeah I'll pay for it like I just want to
I'm like cool and I'm the I'm the
opposite in the way we're like the most
permanent poppers and I know is Gio's
mom we just might roast the [ __ ] out
over all the time but then people like
Steve are like David who can take it all
day long there's no point in me doing it
because I already know what their
comfort zone is but then so it's like if
the mic testing boundary I like [ __ ]
around a lot I going the opposite
direction of what that was this guy
what makes this person well if I could
find someone's buttons yes
I'm like hi I locked it get to play
around and ultimately this you know I
was back part of me but ultimately I
have had people thank me for version of
buttons the only because I was I pushed
them in a way that made them go I was
taking that part of me a little too
seriously that's all yeah yeah it
doesn't always work out by the way that
can be [ __ ] up sometimes yeah but
sometimes it
has been why I have close friends why'd
you ask oh yeah we just change the title
of this video and save this for another
video biggest difference between like
you and Joe and what Joe is talking
about is that when you're on this tour
group that Bart's talking about you're
not saying yeah I haven't masturbated
for five days while Joe's like I'm
masturbating right now and you know what
the women that accept me they accept me
the whole me the crazy me and that's why
I feel like accepted I [ __ ] love that
and to me it's like they it does this
filtering right so it's almost like they
enjoy my sense of humor they're not
gonna be turned off by that and on top
of that they're more likely to be weird
like me and so I don't have this feeling
of being wrong for being myself which I
feel like to me dating is hard because
most of society they're way more
reserved and they're way more that way
and they see me as entertainment opposed
to as a mate does and as your date
you're like [ __ ] you're wrong again and
you're wrong again and you're wrong it's
it's taxing and not only that like the
dating world just like picking up and
hooking up and and that's a different
people are pretending they're not
they're just like they're trying to
impress each other they're trying to be
something and and what I mean impress
it's like it doesn't mean that I'm not
gonna look good for my date or anything
like that it means like people were
putting up a facade
that's the part that bothers me the most
where I'm like there's no need like just
be straight up like exactly why why put
up a front and then pretend that you're
something that you're not and then later
on the truth is gonna come out and is
gonna come and bite you in the ass
that's a game that I don't want to play
and some of these people they truly
don't know who they are they're just
trying things out so that they can build
an identity around them and I think that
a lot of that deal goes missing
sometimes and we all talk about it only
because like for example when when me
and Nicky got together through the first
couple years we would go to like say a
house party or something and
like like it's like wine and my couples
and like it's fun and I [ __ ] love it
right I could stay there for like ten
hours and and these places like the
nobody's leaving everyone's having fun
but nikki has a meter and that meter
goes down and down and down as she
socializes and she has to get the [ __ ]
out at a certain point and I was not
taking that into account
I was just thriving so much that
eventually she's just like yo when we
when we need to leave I need to leave
because I can't do it anymore energy
energy wise in it really and it really
[ __ ] with me and so as soon as she come
over me now when it's time to leave I
don't do what I used to do is just say
bye to everybody and like something on
whatever I just I [ __ ] get out of
there and and that little adjustment has
helped me understand her more because
like what Casey goes through is he's
just trying to identify with people
right and that could be exhausting oh
yeah for sure it's kind of like it's and
maybe it's an introvert thing introvert
versus extroverted thing but for me it's
like it feels like when you're meeting
someone there's a lot of energy spent on
making sure that you want them to like
you
you know and and that energy is like
really taxing whereas like someone like
Joe I feel like you don't have like this
necessity to really need someone to like
like you even though you're aware of it
yeah but you're aware of it but there's
using goal like balls-deep with being
open right now a part that you're saying
that you get exhausted from well it's
not it's more like um it's not fun so
it's it's a waste of energy so it's not
it's not like it tires me out it's maybe
it's hard to explain but fun part to me
is when the barriers are broken and I
see them and they see me that's the real
fun and and when people are straight up
like there are girls that just want to
hook up and then they say hey I want you
true that's [ __ ] awesome don't have
you know I'm not gonna judge you I'm not
gonna pretend that you're oh you know
say I'm not gonna ask you or whatever
like or if they just I don't know man
it's it's it's I think that knowing that
human in the purest form to me is way
more fun than the game everyone has to
play how's your day
are you doing oh cool what do you do for
work you know I don't even know your new
truth searching for something that
connect on is very very tiring for
example like like I love movies right
and some people come up to me and
they're like oh I like movies too and
then we start talking but I'm like oh
you don't really like movies the way I
like movies and so when are we talking
about movies it's really taxing because
I kind of sew cases just judging them
the whole time yeah a little bit it's
like oh we like movies differently yeah
differently differently no he does they
don't really like [ __ ] yeah but it's
definitely different
yet the tiptoe tiptoe all of a sudden
versus like really diving into the
nitty-gritty that makes you excited as
like the conversation goes on right yeah
I think the difference is maybe for
introverts there's the the feeling of
you're sucking my [ __ ] energy [ __ ]
and it's is it it's not worth it and in
four extra words it's you're not
stimulating me enough so it's not worth
it - I got [ __ ] ready I'm sitting
here and now I have to damn we also can
go into spectator mode which is like if
I'm talking to somebody who likes movies
that I think are [ __ ]
I can I can just listen it's almost I
get because the podcast about something
that I had never heard of before or if
somebody likes this movie and I'm like
oh that's fascinating tape mainly like
my view when I interact with people it's
mainly like oh let me understand I'm
trying to understand your perspectives
because I don't see it like that at all
so that's interesting that's my default
setting me too
why are you such an idiot that is my
decent defaults tonight Taylor nice
[Music]
[Music]